Now let's take a look at the hardware
security support in iOS devices.
Each iOS device has a dedicated AES-256
crypto engine built into the direct
memory access path between the flash
storage and the main system memory.
This makes file encryption
highly efficient.
Recall that AES-256 means that
the key length is 256-bit.
The device's unique ID or UID,
and the device group ID or GID,
are AES-256 bit keys fused or compelled
into the application processor,
a secure enclave during manufacturing.
This means that no software or
firmware can read them directly.
They can see only
the results of encryption or
decryption operations performed
by the dedicated AES engines
implemented in silicon using the UID or
GID as a key.
This is an important feature because
the keys are stored securely in
the hardware.
The UIDs are unique to each device and
are not recorded by Apple or
its suppliers.
The GIDs are common to all
processors in a class of devices.
For example, all devices
using the Apple A8 processor.
The GIDs are used for tasks such as
delivering system installation and
updates.
Again, a unique feature of iOS
devices is that the UID and
GID keys are directly
burned in the silicon and
they can be only accessed
by the Crypto Engine.
And the Crypto Engine itself
is part of the hardware.